[Music]
in this task your challenge will be to
build and design an aerodynamic glider
you'll have access to unlimited
resources but time is limited so choose
wisely and design carefully
[Music]
the mathematics of projectile motion
will be key in this challenge as you
design and build gliders be careful
though you'll need to balance the weight
and lift of your glider for the best
aerodynamics otherwise you won't win
this challenge so let's talk about
building a glider there's a bunch of
things that you'll get to choose in this
challenge and
a set of other things that really you'll
kind of be restricted on so i'm going to
kind of tell you those in hand right
firstly
when you build your glider and it might
look something like this uh the first
important thing is where is the center
of mass for your glider right in other
words if you were just carrying it the
center of mass or what we call the
barrier center you could actually let's
just see if i probably can't do it on
this you could balance your finger on it
let's find it and it would
stay exactly in place a bit like how a
basketball i might spin a ball and they
would have their finger in exactly the
right spot and it just spins around on
that to find the center of mass or
rather to
like where do you want the center of
mass of your glider you can actually
find the center of mass of a straight
object like say the fuselage of the
glider that you build by i'm doing
something really simple if you just take
two fingers
do this just move your fingers in
one of the cool things is what's slowing
down my fingers is friction
and the further away i am from the
center of mass the more friction is
applied so i'm not deliberately like
thinking about where i'm moving my
fingers i'm just moving them
independently of each other and they
eventually settle on the center of mass
right so physics kind of does that by
itself i didn't know like i didn't need
to measure that and even if there were
actually weights inside this so that it
wasn't evenly balanced i might measure
out and say oh i think it's there the
center of mass might be somewhere else
like i could have put masses here and
that process of just going to the middle
will find that center of mass
where do you want your center of mass to
be
you can put it anywhere but have a think
about what would happen if you had
you've got this made out of bolsa wood
for example you will have some other
things that you'll need to carry on your
glider some bits of metal and that kind
of thing which will weigh down your
aircraft you tell me what would happen
if the center of mass was near the front
of the glider
it's just going to nose dive isn't it
right so you want to distribute
your masses so that it's going to be
somewhere actually near the center more
specifically
have a think about where it is in
relation to the wings
probably just a little bit behind the
wings is the best place to go but you'll
actually be able to test that out okay
so that's the first thing center of mass
the second thing is
when you think about
how to get lift on your glider right
you've got your wings which you're going
to be making out of balsa wood but if
you just have them horizontally as air
transfers above and below you're not
going to get enough lift to actually fly
much of a distance so you want to have
this angled at a certain amount okay now
be as precise as you can i think what
you'll find is if this was the actual
fuselage which i've grossly exaggerated
then you want an angle of about five
degrees in here which isn't much so you
really need to measure carefully because
even if you're off by one degree right
in this case one degree is 20 so it can
really make a big difference yep
um you are going to make your fuselage
out of a piece of ball sword this part's
important you'll need to measure it
you're limited to 50 centimeters that's
the longest that you can make it but in
terms of the wingspan that's up to you
however i think you'll work out
eventually
that there's a natural limit to how wide
you can make this if you make it really
really wide think about this right
there's going to be more drag on the
front of this so it's going to slow you
down and you'll need to balance that out
yourselves and you can make those
decisions okay
now
i talked about choices that you can make
so this five degrees is one that i would
encourage you to get to as close as
possible but then you have some genuine
options depending on what your design
looks like and then how you want to fire
it so most of you probably know if we
think about projectile motion if you
have a flat surface and you're firing an
object off into the air number one
what's the shape of what's the name of
that shape
that's actually a parabola so you can
get that by a quadratic equation you
will always get a parabola of some kind
if you fire at a lower angle
you might go like this right and if you
fire a higher angle something like this
you're going to have a choice of what
angle of projection you fire at it's
going to be somewhere between 15 degrees
that's the lowest you can do and 45
which i don't think i've really drawn on
here that'll be the highest that you can
choose
you also can decide
how far or rather how much force you're
going to apply when you actually launch
your aircraft when you launch your
glider now you're not just going to be
throwing it okay that would be a bit
imprecise you're going to use an elastic
launcher so the more tension you put
into that elastic the harder it's going
to go maybe you don't want it to go
quite as hard because that's going to
make your um it's going to make your
aircraft fly up and then come back and
hit you you have to be quite careful
about that okay
when you are doing your design we're not
just going to look at how it flies we're
actually going to look at your
construction you want to think about
things like not just the wings which are
providing lift but these things back
here these sort of fins does anyone have
any ideas what purpose do they serve
fantastic so in order to have it
actually fly in a straight line things
like these actually provide stability to
your aircraft so we want to look for
things like that we want to also look
for things like symmetry this has been
designed and built and manufactured so
it's going to be symmetrical but you're
going to be creating your gliders by
hand so carefully designing measuring
out and then actually creating the
shapes of your materials you need to be
very cautious
i'm so excited to see what you build do
be careful because these these materials
do get damaged easily so you want to
factor that into your design as well
good luck teams let's start building 10.
this one here
seven
six five four
three
two
one